the joggin experience I want to talk
about something you brought up briefly
earlier about the media being sort of
cheerleaders yeah for a lot of these
Wars or a lot of these military actions
what do you think that that happens
because this ensures that they get
access do you think it happens because
conflict is good for their business do
you think it happens because if they
don't act as cheerleaders that they
don't get access to the leaders and to
the important politicians and military
leaders I mean I I think that the
underlying driver is that conflict is
good for ratings that's crazy that that
is their decision how to cover things
it's it's the it's the war machine you
know that that they're a part of and
that they're driving that they are a
driving force for you know I think that
yeah there there you know there there
have been reports I think over time I 18
you on Matt Taibbi here resume where
you've got you know journalists who are
more or even you know papers who are who
are more interested in covering for
their you know CIA relationships rather
than actually bringing forward a story
that the American the truth you know
that the American people deserve to hear
so you know I think there there are
other factors there that drive the media
really playing a heavily influential and
dangerous force in continuing to push
this this war mongering narrative that
that is you know I mean it's it's costly
in an immeasurable in a measurable way
well the coverage is so influential and
that influence it changes the way people
accept or don't accept things that are
happening internationally you know when
there's something I mean what was the
with do you remember one oh there was a
time when Obama had talked about
attacking Syria yes doing something
endless in 2013 the entire country was
like [ __ ] you like it was it was she was
my first year in Congress I mean it was
one of the the biggest like rejections
of an idea global or a nationally that
I've ever seen and then he kind of
backed off it and you know I was like oh
okay I think I think that was one
of the most brave decisions that he made
to back off from it where he actually
you know he didn't take that position in
that example of just kind of being the
obstinate stubborn like nope here's what
I said and he drew this red line and I'm
not gonna go back on it no matter what
no he did I think he listened to the
American people and ultimately he chose
diplomacy well this is an area where
people have been critical of you is your
position on Syria and the fact that you
had met with Assad and this is something
that gets brought up and again it gets
brought up in these little soundbite
things that are seeking to define you
without any nuance or any any complexity
to try to let light just let this little
tiny sentence or to define your position
then they can repeat that to other
people without really knowing what
they're talking about yeah what is your
position on Syria and Assad and how did
all this conflict and all this weirdness
with you and the subject begin I think I
think it it goes back to again the the
opposition that comes towards me from
the the political establishment you know
the the corporate media in the
military-industrial complex because of
the the leadership and the voice that
I've been bringing calling for an end to
regime change wars whether we're talking
about the one in Iraq Libya and in in
Syria but my choice my choice will
always be towards diplomacy because if
we lack the courage to meet with both
adversaries and friends in the pursuit
of our own national security and peace
the only alternative is war period
that's the way it is so I will always
choose to maximize all diplomatic means
and measures and talks and negotiations
to further our interests of peace and
national security
recognizing that war should always be
the last resort if necessary now is this
it's very difficult for people to
understand that these things are
insanely mess
see and you saying that you would always
lean towards diplomacy does not mean you
support dictators no but that's exactly
the way they frame it yeah but if you
look at the famous Hillary Clinton
speech after Qaddafi was killed we Came
we saw he died and she was laughing
Libya is a failed state now they have
they have slaves that they're auctioning
off on YouTube and you could watch slave
auctions that someone filmed with their
camera on their phone and they upload it
to YouTube Libya's gone I mean it's a
chaotic place right now yeah it wasn't
good when Qaddafi was running Libya but
it wasn't as bad as it is now so the
idea that supporting Qaddafi is
supporting a dictatorship and you're
your own monster for supporting and like
maybe not because it's kind of worse now
because the world is a very messy place
and it's not even a matter of
quote-unquote supporting it's just
saying hey we're not going to come in
and overthrow you and right government I
think that's as it seems that that's the
issue here and the contradiction when
people are criticizing me for exercising
diplomacy and calling for an end to the
regime change war that we've been waging
in Syria since 2011 but then they'll say
oh well of course I was against
overthrowing Saddam Hussein in Iraq
right there there's no intellectual
there's no consistency there and I think
the the issue with Libya that that so
often gets overlooked is again we look
at what what will the consequences be of
these regime change wars you said I mean
Libya is a completely failed state there
are more terrorist organizations and
strongholds in Libya now than there ever
were before when Gaddafi was there the
people of Libya are suffering far more
now than they were before we also see
this other effect on our own national
security where our to our regime change
war policy has undermined our ability to
negotiate with Kim jong-un in North
Korea towards denuclearization you have
the leaders of North Korea of time and
time again have said hey look we're
developing nuclear weapons as the only
deterrent that
work against the United States coming in
and overthrowing our governments set it
over and over and over again and they've
pointed to examples like Libya saying
that well you guys are saying you want
to come in and negotiate with us to get
rid of our nuclear weapons
you told Gaddafi the same thing today
Gaddafi get rid of your nuclear weapons
program we'll leave you alone and then
you went in and overthrew Gaddafi why
will this be any different with us and
then you've got John Bolton as as then
the National Security Director for for
Trump going on television or giving
speeches saying yeah you know we're
gonna approach North Korea with the
Libya model he said that and so when we
wonder like hey why aren't these and I I
think I think Trump was right now I said
it publicly Trump is right to have
direct negotiations with Kim jong-un but
he hasn't gotten anywhere and you've got
to look at why and this is one of the
reasons why continuing hey hey no we're
not gonna overthrow you in your
government Kim Jong and but on the other
hand you're you're continuing the
policies that directly undermine your
ability to to make that agreement that
that'll be that'll that'll hold and that
will stand as a result now you know we
have North Korea that that's nuclear
weapons program is continuing to
escalate their capabilities are
continuing to grow and it poses a threat
not only to you know my folks in Hawaii
the people of Hawaii given our proximity
North Korea but their capabilities now
they're extending across the west coast
they're extended extending across the
country posing a very direct existential
threat to our country and to our people
so you see how that decision that was
made about Libya these decisions that
are ongoing see they're pulling out of
the Iran nuclear agreement North Korea
says hey you guys made an agreement them
you got a different president elected
tore up that agreement why should we
think that's going to be any different
with us
so these policy decisions that are being
made are very directly connected in in
having the effect ultimately of
undermining our national security and
making the American people less safe
[Applause]